when we wanted to do Forge 45 we really
wanted to go nuts with it using the this
new power that we have with Xbox one
what can we do to make it so basically
users can build fast and easy and that's
really where our goal was to start from
there so this week we've invited five
community members we call them
cartographers five people who have been
playing forge since Forge was around to
start playing with these guys are
spending a whole week here with us
they're doing things that would have
taken them at four days to do in like a
couple minutes now this Forge is insane
all the suggestions that the community
has had over the years they decided to
put in their lighting effects more
terrain pieces more rocks you have round
objects appropriating colors or objects
we have the system in forge now called
grouping where you can grab objects and
you can group them together and now 20
or 100 or 400 objects will act exactly
as the one object I made my entire base
once I the map group the whole thing
together shifted it and then move it
across the map how's it having these
really solid foundations and they're
really finding their vision in their
voice and the maps will help us deliver
better maps for the Canadian longer it's
just so much more you really did not
expect this we're just blown away with
the new features most of the stuff that
we have always been asked before is in
the game now everything's new the
controls are nearing the contents the
tools are new I can barely sleep they're
just dreaming of using the new tool
systems while it might be hobbyist at
this point we'll see in the future
because I'm gonna be creating a lot
unimax get the xbox one limited edition
bundle